Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Prison Architect
Now a lot of people have wanted me to play this game for a long time
and I haven't gotten around to it.
uh, mostly because I forgot about it
But I'm playing it now, I've never played it before
and I don't imagine it's a lot like The Escapist,
which is more a game where you have to get OUT of a prison
as a pose to getting in.
Hello, CEO!
"This is a tough one."
"There's a prisoner incarcerated at this facility
who's been convicted of a double murder and sentenced to death."
Well, that's starting off on a cheerful note!
"That's where we come in.
We've been contracted to construct an execution chamber in time for the big guy's big day."
OH BOY
That CEO has too much of a smile on his face for this subject matter.
But oh well. Okay.
I didn't expect this to be as dark at this was.
"This is where I want the new facility to be built."
I WANT MORE EXECUTIONS!
I WANNA MAXIMIZE OUR EXECUTIONABLE EFFICIENCY!
I wanna do all the stuff we can.
"The first step with any project like this
is to construct the building itself
with enough space inside to fit an execution room and a holding cell."
So the guy in the holding cell can see his DOOM before it approaches
and know what he's getting himself into.
"So let's get started. Construct a new building here."
Okay, "We will also need an entrance to
entrance to the new execution facility
the new Execution facility."
Yeah we can have people bashing
yeah we can't have people bashing
through walls so eager to get in there
Ugh...
build a large jailed door in the south
wall
into the south wall." Okay.
ok foundation brick building who are
biome building object large Dale door
Foundation, brick building
Wha-bam
Building, object,
Large Jail Door,
<ringing> huckaboofke!
Okay, got it. I did it,
I did it boss aren't you proud of me
boss
boss. Aren't you proud of me, boss?
"Your workmen are responsible for the
your workmen are responsible for the
construction of buildings
construction of buildings.
they'll collect the steel and concrete
from this storm and take it to the
They'll collect the steel and concrete
from this store room and take it to the construction site."
construction site
Well that's handy of them.
well that's handy of them hope they
don't do anything wrong or else they'll
Hope the don't do anything wrong, or else they'll find
themselves in jail.
find themselves in jail they'll use
those raw materials to build the
"They'll use those raw materials to build the foundations of
foundation and framework of your new
building
framework of your new building.
This is the slowest part of the construction,
this is the slowest part of the
construction so you should plan ahead
so you should plan ahead when building new facilities.
when building new facilities
While we wait, take a look around.
while we wait take a look around using
WASD and arrow keys to move around use
Use the WASD or arrow keys to move around
the mouse wheel to zoom in and out
and use the mouse wheel to zoom in and out.
Okay!
ok oh I have a lovely prison if you can
say that about a prison I definitely
Oooh! I have a lovely prison!
If you can say that about a prison, I definitely have one.
have one
I wonder which one of these assholes is
currently planning his escape
Which one of these assholes is currently planning his escape?
well they see you well I spot I spy a
problem already
Well, they seem (plubth) I spy a problem already!
all of the jail cell doors seem to be
open
All of the jail cell doors seem to be open!
Hmm... OH!
Wow, that's actually a pretty efficient cooking staff.
That's the thing about prisons, they get three square meals a day.
that's the thing about prisons they get
three square meals a day
I mean, I'm not saying that like that's a benefit!
I mean I'm not saying that like that's a
benefit but i'm saying they efficiently
But I'm saying they efficiently do that good. ANYWAY.
do that sort of you i'm not going to
make any political statements or
I'm not going to make any political statements or anything
anything that I'm just prisons are bad
especially here in America but prisons
I'm just... Prisons are bad!
Especially here in America, but Prisons are BAD!
hello inside the building i want to sell
in an execution room
Hello!
Inside the building I want a cell and an execution room.
You got it boss!
you got it boss anything for you
partition the space by constructing some
Anything for you
Partition the space by building some brick walls.
brick walls
okay brick walls haha boink and a boy
Ooooookay, brick walls. Kaboink... and ahboink.
I did it and boink and a boring and i'm
guessing you want some
I did it, and ahboink and ahboink and I'm guessing you want some
*mark.exe is buffering*
probably some doors in between those but
i don't know exactly what you want it
Probably some doors inbetween those.
But I don't know exactly what you want
inbetween the doors
oh man you guys are slow but things seem
to be going well
oh yeah this is a for-profit prison
which exists in real life which is a
very bizarre thing but it does exist
so we gotta maintain the
correct prison population to be able to
do what we need to do
hi Stacey what are you doing in there was it..
ah I thought I thought that was going
to say something else way mark fairborn okay
all right done
we did it now at large jail doors to
those dividing walls
you can rotate an object before
placement by clicking the middle mouse
button (or press R) yeah I could have
done that before i actually got in there
shieet... no... stop that... okay .
Boink
got it
bada boop 4x
*Unclear noises*
Good thing they just got those in storage...
alright we did it cool, "That's looking
good now we need to designate rooms
within those spaces", for the killing
this one's the killing space
this is the killing corner that's the
corner where they cry
The Crying corner in the killing corner
oh boy
all right... designated as an execution
room
you got it...
urrrgghhhh
*Weapon's Ready...*
*Pfffffftttt*(Weapon's fired)
YEEEAAAHHHH
execution whoo hoo hoo ha ha ho man
it is doesn't feel right, "These new rooms
have requirements before they become
functional",
yeah like the kill detonator 2000, "the
cell needs a bed and a toilet
the execution requires the electric
chair", Oh were in that stage of
technology we don't need any lethal
injections here
good old-fashioned electricity worked in the Green Mile
it can work here too haha ok anyway
*Heavy Breathing* I probably should rotate that so
it's actually usable and not faced up
against the wall and I want this to be
dead center
shit, dead center so that everyone can
gather around in a big circle and watch
him fry, oh boy
alrighty then speed it up, boink . it's eating
time apparently
hello friends! how's it going in here? Oh
were they fighting i couldn't tell
they're fighting
yeah whatever.  hi Thomas, no not the light
paul thomas sentenced to five years
for kidnapping
he's got a whole family too. Oh I can
punish him?
I don't know if I want to do that yet, ok
"That's the essential is taken care of
but there's still a few improvements you
could make.It's up to you though
these aren't strictly required. It depends
on how much you care about your
prisoners in their environment".
You know, their well-being right before
they get blasted through the brain with
10,000 amps of..err.. I don't know
killed dead
ok, "The cell itself could be improved
with an outward facing window and a
small bookshelf".
Whoa the execution room could be
improved with live streams for the whole
world to enjoy, "And the facility would
look better with a higher quality floor
material like wooden floorboards or
mosaic tiles".
uh-huh. "Outside you could add some
lighting and a paved pathway if you
think it needs it".
oh its my... the world is literally my
oyster.
I get to make whatever the hell I want
to make. It sounds delightful!
ok, and who is...oh is this... is this the guy?
hello! ah, ooh. we're doing the slow zoom to
raise the heightening dramatisism of
this one moment
"This is the man in question, Edward
Romsey,". Well, I hope it's not in question!!
Danggg it! "A teacher once would you believe.
it's not our place to decide if he
deserves this
the laws made that decision. We're just
here to do a job once you're satisfied
the facility is ready, you can begin the
transition transferred to his new cell
simply click on the Polaroid in his cell
to initiate the transfer".
Oh? Oh Okay.
Ah, so  before I do that can I add some
niceties to this.
Oooh! Oohhh!
All right, let me add a paved path
because that probably is necessary
Was this the right one? I hope so!
We're gonna get a nice doublewide on this bad
boy there
that's real pretty looking. we're going
to get some marble tile in here *giggles* so that it looks--- Oh! That just made it look more sinister!
I don't think it's quite done but it's
there. All right
bookshelf! you know, necessary
Ba-boink! a window, for the outwards
how do we make that outwards? I-- wait no
hang on, an outwards facing window!
okay that's good. oh! that is a delightful
flooring, Oh so tasteful! (Kissing noises) Perfect!
perfect for the electric chair! Ugh. alright
so that's--- paving is in progress I guess
that's all the path, so lights need to go
Oinkiity boink! and then boink! and then
boingy blink! that look real good I
imagine, wait
those--- do  those go? ok it did go, ok it's
good
ok so they got him definitely. that looks
lovely
now everyone's gonna be happy except
for the guy that's gonna die.
Okay, I added a bookshelf in the window, is that happening?
I hope so.I think it's happening
I think it happened.  I'm not a hundred
percent sure, hope that window got there
yeah the window got there. ok and then
the bookshelf.  hurry up man your last in
line I don't care if you have to haul
around an entire bookshelf by yourself
you stop complaining and do your job
really you find--- you don't know where? all
right way anyway, so that is done. i got all of
that
thankfully I'm to advance. Oooh... the chief
I don't like the look of the chief. the
chief gives me the heebie-jeebies
He reminds me exactly of the chief from Shawshank Redemption
oh boy mmm whoa man
Oh I did--- Oh I need to--- Ohhh... I don't know, he's just so gritty with the polaroid and
moustache. and his cheekbones are to die
for, literally. "Don't shed one tear for
this guy he's a stone-cold
killer, guilty as charged
He even confessed. want to hear his
description of what he did?"
no I'm fine. I didn't think I would be
inundated with this many moral
obligations
"It's juicy stuff" Oh god stop talking
"It was around 11pm, the lights were
already on
I knew she was home..." Eugh, I don't wanna--- Nooo, oh god.
oh god, oh no.I didn't know this
was going to be part of it
I thought it was just gonna be a
simulator game
Oh no!
Oh! Oh okay?
What the hell! Oh my god!
Good golly! "I knew I'd catch you two here."
Wow. Edwards wife Susan, oh yeah okay
"Edward". "Don't just"--- Ahh  I don't want to
read this
Ugh I don't want to read this! Oh god.
Ugh! *Mark Screams*
*gunshot*
*scream*
*another gunshots*
*Mark screams*
Oh! "Clear as day if you ask me. deserves
every volt he's gonna get".
Wow! here I thought it was gonna be a
happy fun game
Wow! "All men deserve forgiveness even him
are you so sure in yourself that you can
deal out such final judgment?"
"Catching your wife with another man is no excuse
for what he did and he went there with a
loaded gun knowing he'd find them
together
that's double premeditated murder..."
"He's done nothing but co-operate with the
authorities
this state is making an example out of
him if he committed his crime a hundred
miles north
he'd be looking at life imprisonment
instead how is that justice?"
"Do you want a guy like this running free?
I'll sleep just fine at night when he's
when I know he's gone".
Oh my goodness this game is so much
heavier
oh... then I... I never thought it was like
this
I had no idea, "Good work so far" yeah I
feel good
oh my god I... I was... games are supposed to
be fun and happy
not really but you know I thought this
one was going to be
"However there is one problem the
execution room isn't"...
I thought there was going to say isn't "FUN" yet "...because it
doesn't have any power
we need to connect it to the electrical
supply..."
*HEAVY BREATHING* O...K...
wow that looks fancy and interesting how
do I do this
"We are now viewing the prison in
utilities mode shows us the electrical
wiring layout for the entire prison".
oh my god what did you do to my eyes how
could I say this.
"Each building in the prison is connected
to the power grid by these thick
underground electrical cables".
ah can these be sabotaged? "Power is
provided the prison by the substation
which draws electricity from the
National Grid".
ok heh so prisoners could probably
break that down and then cause all of
the things to open. "As you can see this
entire wing of the prison cells is
without power all the lights are out to
fix this problem we first need to switch
into utilities mode
to understand why the lights were without
power". Well it's because the big wire
no connect to over there
I've solved it with my big brain (congrats Mark).
"The
nearest electrical cables are too far
away
our engineers can complete the wiring
for this area. Extend the electrical
cables nearby to cover this wing in the
prison".
ok... utilities mode!
electrical cables!
*weird noises*
I DID IT!!!
I DID GOOD!
did I get it? Do I need to do the individual ones or  is going to happen i think is
gonna happen normally right? ooohhhh aaergh that
doesn't look good
it needs to be rotated no that's fine don't
they'll fix it
yeah they'll fix it i thought they would
yeah go my little minions go ooohhh look at
them
*giggle* they work so well bididing! and then i'm
guessing i need to connect this over to
here *a lot of bing bada boom*
ok oh geez okay. "Lights aren't the only
thing that needs power your new electric
chair does too".
oh! I never would have thought I was
gonna try to put two and two together
but my brain can't handle those numbers
with what I just experienced. "Use the
power cables to connect the execution
facility to the power grid".
ok i did that. "The electric chair itself
is a special type of electrical item
it requires its own dedicated power line
you need to connect it up directly with
the main cables".
I wonder why its amperage is so high
ok alrighty then I think I did it already
oh man these guys work tirelessly boy do
i what are these guys doing out here
are you lost? go home! geez you don't want
to be here for this
all right. "We're almost done i think we
should test the new execution room at
least once before we try to use it
oh no... OH next thing I know it's gonna
find a small animal that test it on my
god don't do it it's... "I'm just going to
turn it on for a few seconds
make sure everything is ok". And make
sure nothing's in there
don't even bother looking
huh geez
whoa wow that's not good
well... shit, "Well that didn't work looks
like we do too much power and trip the
circuit breaker in the power station
the whole prison is dark we're going to
need more juice to be able to handle the
power spike to the electric chair
generates". OK... alright
"First we need to turn the power back on
this is a two-step process
switch the power station back on by
clicking on it and selecting the switch
on in the menu that appears then build
three more capacitor so we have enough
power capacity to handle the electric
chair
once you've done that test the electric
chair again by clicking on it and switch
selecting switch on the main menu".
you got it I thought follow dismantle,
switch on there we go
badooom... okay so we need more capacitors
of coursey course... yeah that should be
enough
once those are built it's going to be good
seriously why do they just wander around
in that area over there and then wander
around outside
why couldn't you guys who are sticking
around here actually do something and
help out over there
good golly Miss Molly you guys are not
helpful at all
ok badoom 3x ok so now i should
be able to test it out
okay. "Well done". I don't feel like I
did a job well done "I believe we are
finished with this job
what happens now is out of our hands we
did a professional job and that's
important in our business".
yes this is "business" juuuuust "business"
"Try not to worry about what happens next..."
of course I'm worried
of course I'm worried oh man
*breathe*
oh...
wow...
"Can I help you?"     "..."
"Are you looking for forgiveness?"
"I don't know.. I have to do something I
can't live with the things I've done."
"You have to turn yourself in whatever
you've done you cannot evade the
consequences."
"You will never be able to live with
yourself until you face up to your past".
"I want to go back... I want to forgive her...
I want her to forgive me". "God will
"forgive you no matter what you've done"
"if you asked him to"
"but you must answer for your crimes in
the eyes of the law"
"there is no other way". Ok this is so... oh my goodness...
"It is time Edward you have done the"
"right thing even though this world will
not forgive you for it"
"you will be with God soon and he will
have the final judgment on you".
oh-ho-ho
sooo heavy... oh-ho-ho no... oh man
see on the surface what threw me off is
this game looks so simplistic and I
assumed that it would be more happy fun
just a gamey game
I had no idea that it actually had like
a story... ohhh
boohoo Oh-ho... oh-ho... also i imagine that this
is in another time period . probably in the
fifties or sixties or something like
that because... uuuh...
uhh man...2x
uhh......
oh yeah the hood
yeah the hoods a nice touch oh no... it
looks ohh...
Oh... oh "Edward Romsey you've been found
guilty of two counts of murder in the"
"first degree"
"the penalty is death do you have
anything to say?"
"Susan..." ohhh
"...I'm sorry".
chapter 2
oh my goodness... see I came into this
oh ok what the hell is that? oh that's not
good...
I know if you... ohh! "There is a crisis
brewing at one of our other facilities"
yeah no kidding! "Someone started a fire
in the prison kitchen
the priority is to put it out, stop any
casualties, and prevent more damage
use the emergency services button in the
toolbar to call the fire brigade, get
this fire under control before it burns
the whole prison down".
okay, where? here? there! bam!
fire it up! how do I do this?
what do i do I am so confu-- OH GOD its
spreading
well do I call both them? I'm calling both, we're
calling both of them, bringing the whole
squad
oh jeez oh jeez you might want to hurry
the frick up
what are you doing? what are you doing?? get over there!
get in there!
oh geez oh garsh oh god that
looks bad
oh gosh that looks bad,  Oh God how do
i-- how do i extinguished-- oh do i-- oh oh
do I have to like...
waaaat oh oh here th-there
I don't know? what do you want? right
click the right mouse
oh I didn't know that! I'd-I'd-I'd fighted
known I would have done it
oh geez oh God I didn't know! I didn't
know! you didn't know!
oh lordy Lou oh god they're trying to get
out
oh man... that must be a bad situation
to try to control the prisoners
oh man they're all scrambling to get out
oh wow
spray it! spray hard! all three deaths
who died who died was there anybody in
there
I didn't know there was anybody in there
oh-- OH!!!
OH NO!!!
OHHH!!!
ohh i didn't mean it..
oh no...
Holy crap...
oh rescue him! rescue him!
rescue him... he's still alive in there...
wow!... they legitimately like, risk their
lives...
whoa that is nuts...
that is nuts...
I... didn't even know that I was like oh
man I care so much about these little
dots... dont walk in the fire!
oh don't stand right in the fire... he's
standing right in the fire...
oh you're still ok-- oh you're still
okay ah
oh he just went unconscious ok that's
not good oh... I had no idea
ok... so now that the fire has been put out
I think... for the most part there's still
a little ember over there let me go get
that...
don't, don't stand in the fire just put
it out thank you
okay now that that's done now that the
crisis is solved... "My god there's a
survivor in the wreckage".
Oh... is he the one that started the fire I
have no idea
"Christ on a crutch"
"it's Don Palermo of all the inmates, it
just had to be our mob boss" *laughs*
ok... "The bad news for him is that the
budget cuts have meant we had exact all"
"our permanent doctors"
"the good news is our infirmary is still
usable hire a couple of doctors and"
"they'll take care of Don palermo whilst
we sort this mess out"
oh wow. "We need to clear up this mess"
"use the bulldoze to demolish the ruin
canteen in kitchen"
"you need to remove all the debris" ... ok
"Designated a garbage zone adjacent to the
road are workmen will dump the wreckage"
"therefore the garbage trucks to dispose
of. finally can you send those firemen"
"home now that they've done their job" and
a few of them died
"I've added more details on each of these
objectives in your "to do" list"
"anytime you're unsure what to do"
"highlight the objective and you'll
see additional instructions". Ok...
Wow... whoo man...
okay, I'm gonna end this episode here
just because I need to wrap my head
around what the hell just happened but,
wow this game is way way way way more
involved than I thought it was that is
nuts... but, that's prison architect
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm gonna play some more of this game
I want to know more I came into this,
thinking I just got done playing
Blueprint Tycoon and I thought it was
gonna be kinda like that
I had no idea so this is going to be a
wild experience for me
I am very eager to see what is this
tucked away why is there a fireman's
thing? is that a fireman thing? I have no
idea this the type i'm aware of
but, either way it's gonna be a wild ride so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video, buh bye!
WHAT!? That was a good option, that was a good option
ok Oh down here, Oh good let me just
sort through this with so much care
fuck this guy